BRAC good evening to you since the
questions that robert muller wants to
ask president Trump obtained by Fox News
were made public there has been great
debate about the prudence of President
Trump sitting for an interview with
robert muller after our conversation
with Rudy Giuliani this afternoon Fox
News has learned that decision process
is still very much in flux news about
the Russia investigation a rapidly
moving target today with the newest
member of President trumps legal team
Rudy Giuliani telling Fox News the jury
is still out about a sit-down with
robert muller position isn't determined
yet keep an open mind but i'm concerned
about are they objective about the
president's no [ __ ] he might be
telling the truth and homie maybe like
if they have an open mind of that then
this is something we would consider if
they don't and given all of your
regularities investigation we would be
forced to have him on the fifty some odd
questions muller wants to ask Giuliani
told Fox News the president and his
legal team fear a perjury trap insisting
there is no way the president will sit
for 12 hours to answer them how long
would Giuliani give Muller and the
questions he says would have to be
narrowly focused relevant topics but it
may not be relevant any longer it was a
cold firing the rest of it the
tangential stuff we'd want to see out
while the president's team isn't yet
convinced about an interview Robert
Muller is pushing hard for one the
president's former lead outside counsel
John Dowd telling Fox News that in a
meeting in early March Muller threatened
to use a subpoena to halt the president
before a grand jury Dowd responded quote
this isn't some game you are screwing
with the work of the President of the
United States the brushback appeared to
have some effect the following week
Muller's deputy James Quarles dictated
the list of
ian's muller wants to ask to doubt and
jay sekulow constitutional law expert
Alan Dershowitz today said based on the
questions President Trump should never
sit for an interview but there may be a
way to avoid a subpoena if I were the
president's lawyer and I'm not let me be
very clear about that I would take
advantage of these questions and I would
submit answers in writing to almost all
of them and then make objections to the
others based on article 2 of the
Constitution and then tell the American
public look I've answered all these
questions why are they trying to bring
me into a grand jury
there was another shake-up in president
Trump's legal team today the president's
in-house counsel on the Russia
investigation
Ty Cobb retiring former Clinton
impeachment attorney Emmett flood taking
over for him at the end of May in a
statement press secretary Sarah Sanders
saying quote Emmett flood will be
joining the White House staff to
represent the president and the
administration against the Russia
witch-hunt
Ty Cobb a friend of the president who
has done a terrific job will be retiring
at the end of the month if the
president's attorneys do agree to an
interview with robert muller it likely
won't happen anytime soon
Giuliani told Fox News that with a
possible summit with North Korean leader
Kim jong-un looming there simply won't
be time to prepare the president for
lengthy testimony until probably
sometime in June if they do agree to it
as well Giuliani told me they want
assurances from the special counsel that
the interview would happen before the
end of the summer he also said Brett
that they are ready for a subpoena
battle should it come to that brett won
this with the panel john roberts live in
the North Lawn John thanks